That's like East coast. Good fellowship. You don't rat you don't rat.
No, that's straight across the board. You don't rat, which is, what's so funny.
Now all these comics trashing other comics on social media.
I just don't understand that. It's just like, what? W like, you've,
you've become like comics already get.
Why would you go if you don't like somebody special or you, or whatever,
you don't like something that they said, I don't know. That's a, that's a new,
uh, phenomenon.
There's a lot of new fall of phenomenons this year. And, um,
I don't want to get into it, but, um, no,
because it's going to deal with stuff that we don't want to talk about.
Like cancel culture and whatnot. You know what I mean?
But in terms of like people ratting people out and you know what I mean?
And it's been a very, uh, difficult thing, you know,
just take an SNL character idea. It's called Twitter, lawyer.
Or lawyer toward a lawyer. Do you have any opening statements? Yes,
your honor. I'm all out of.
The funniest opening statement to just burning down somebody.
Um, but it is, it is what it is. It is what it is, what it is. It is.
Uh, but my generation would have been doing the same thing.
If we came up on 'em on computers and stuff,
it's a weird sort of thing.
It's not like a new mentality.
You think it's just access to a keyboard? No, I think it's the,
uh, the power of not being face-to-face where, when I was growing up,
like there was a rule when I, this is so funny to hear now,
but when I was growing up,
there was a rule you went to a party or somebody invited you over,
you do not bring up politics and you don't bring up religion. And then like,
social media is the inverse where it's just like everything.
You're not supposed to bring up.
You bring up in all rules of common decency are just
out the window. And, and, um, you know, the whole,
Hey, I can't, you know, as a guy growing up, there was always that, you know,
there was there's that line. You learn where the line is.
If I go past that line, I'm risking getting the kicked out of me.
And that is sort of, um, you know, it's like disappeared.
Um, it's funny because.
Like, even there, I have to admit,
like I discovered a couple of comics that I love that are,
that could be, you know, Republicans or whatnot. Right. They're not out.
You hear rumors. And my initial response is what is wrong with that?
I know I'm not, I'm just, there's nothing wrong with this. They're not out,
but not out as Republican, you know, they did, they keep their stuff.
Private is what I meant, because liberals are out of their [inaudible].
I understand that, man. Listen to my point though. Okay. Let me finish my point.
Okay. My initial reaction, like, ah, right.
But it's like, no, it's, I'm just going to make up a name. It's Joey,
he's a good guy. You know what I mean? It's like, you know, it's like.
Nothing to do with it. This listen, bill
volatile, love how judgmental the left is. You don't know anything about it. Oh,
he's a good he's. He is still,
I understand.
But at the end of the day, it's like all these even now, because of the,
of politics and the election, all that stuff. Like I try not to like,
let it ruin or dictate how I feel and whatnot, because at the end of the day,
it doesn't make who you are as a person, you know, your political affiliation,
you know, we, we there's good guys everywhere. There's bad guys everywhere.
And you have a wide variety of people in your life. That's what I'm saying.
It goes back to those alt rooms where it just became, like, it was just,
everybody was it's like, it was the echo chamber of it. That I,
that was what, um,
I found fascinating to go in and do comedy in front of
like that. Like, if you were to graph the people in the room, like,
it was almost like a S like a straight, like there wasn't an, Oh,
this guy does this and this person's over here. It was just sort of like,
you know, like, uh, like, uh, what do you call it? Like, it's just like,
all the dots were like right there, right there. Yeah, yeah. Yeah.
Which made it like, uh,
I don't know. It was so easy to get into trouble, right.
During your set there. Cause it was just like,
there was just one place where you.
Right. You won't have a Brian Holtzman in a room like that. I mean, I would.
Exactly where I would put off. I w I would film it and.
Yeah. But no, I, I think, uh, you know,
that's why I just find that, like, that stuff fascinating. I tried and like, I,
you know, I definitely, you know, I joke about politics and like that, but,
you know, I'm not going to get on somebody cause they're, you know,
like if you say you're liberal, I don't then think like, Oh,
that means that you're you're this, this, I mean, there's so many,
there's the spectrum of being on the left is the spectrum of being on the right.
You know? And, um, I dunno, I'm kind of hoping that we,
we maybe learned something over the last 20 years
of just, you know, everybody just,
like half the country just on whoever's proclaimed.
I really feel like the first George Bush was the last guy who was kind of
allowed to be president without half of his country,
trying to take him out of office, kind of started with the Clinton,
lying under oath about the blow job.
And then it was Bush stole the election and Albana was not from here.
And everything Trump did was just like, you know, I mean,
I don't know how that helps people, but.
It doesn't. And I think we're at a precipice.
And that's why I stopped giving you, Bobby. I was just like, you know what?
I need to bring.
The two coasts. All right.
But here's I want to it's that old boy, right?
I do. Yeah. Oh my God, dude. I got a horror movie, but for people at home,
he told me about this movie,
like 10 years ago and I that one and then the audition.
Oh my God.
I, you invited me to your birthday party one time. Yes. And, uh,
I brought you the DVD of old boy as a gift. Yes you did. Yeah. Yeah.